C'est l'histoire d'un youtubeur, qui vous a parlé du jeu de son enfance, qui vous a ensuite parlé de son adolescence, et qui va aujourd'hui,
vous parler de son enfance tout court.
Pourquoi personne n'est chaud ?
pardonnez ma voix et mes *rffff* reniflements, je suis un peu malade.
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler de mes années écoles primaires je voulais vous en parler parce que j'ai trop d'anecdotes
incroyables plus encore même que quand j'étais adolescent. On va commencer tout de suite avec l'anecdote la plus débile de toutes. j'étais en classe au
milieu des autres élèves et nous étions en cours de math. Je n'arrivais plus à me concentrer car ça me grattait énormément dans l'oreille gauche.
Je regarde alors mon crayon, je vois en lui un gros potentiel
pour se gratter l'intérieur de l'oreille. Mais je m'aperçois aussi que la gomme est comme
fissurée, c'est alors que je me lance un challenge : me gratter l'oreille avec le côté gomme du crayon, sans que la gomme ne reste dans mon
oreille.
Ca a foiré, je me suis gratté si fort que le plaisir se voyait sur mon visage
mais en ressortant le crayon, la gomme n'était plus là, elle était dans mon oreille
c'est alors que j'ai terminé la journée dans le bureau du proviseur à les regardez et essayer de me l'enlever avec une pince à épiler
Un moment de plaisir
Le lendemain j'ai raté l'école car j'ai dû aller chez un médecin spécialisé pour me faire retirer le bout de gomme
peut-être que tout était prévu depuis le début, je sais pas
maman si tu regardes cette vidéo
excuse moi
la morale de l'histoire c'est ne vous lancez jamais de challenge que vous avez entre 7 et 11 ans puisque ça finit toujours mal
la deuxième fois je me suis lancé un challenge
j'sais pas pourquoi je me lançais des challenges, c'est complètement débile mais j'adorais ça quand j'étais petit
j'adorais les bonbons comme tous les enfants, et ma mère comme toutes les mamans les cachait dans un bocal en verre posé sur le frigo
de manière à ce que je puisse pas les atteindre, ce qu'elle avait oublié c'est que dans un appartement t'as aussi des chaises, et des chaises ça rajoute
de la hauteur à ton petit corps de huit ans, je mets une chaise
j'atteins le bocal rempli de bonbons je suis très heureux et en le tirant vers moi je le fais tomber par terre à mes pieds
jvous cache pas dans ma vie j'ai jamais eu autant de bonbons que ce jour là autour de moi mais le problème c'est que j'ai
aussi jamais eu autant de bouts de verre autour de moi et c'est là que le challenge c*n de l'enfant c*n de huit ans arrive
Ok, en descendant délicatement de cette chaise je peux faire un petit saut au-dessus des bouts de verre et m'en sortir indemne à
la seconde où je saute de la chaise, j'atterris sur un bout de verre mon pote
il m'a transpercé le bas du gros doigts de pied et à l'heure actuelle j'ai encore une plaie, à l'époque j'ai pas eu le courage de
dire à ma maman que je m'étais blessé en faisant quelque chose d'interdit, j'avais peur des représailles
vous comprenez du coup je n'ai pas dit que je m'étais blessé mais mec j'aurais dû avoir des points de suture et du coup maintenant
son doigt puis il ya un trou béant aujourd'hui des fois quand je marche ça me fait mal parce que le
le truc est sec et du coup j'sais pas, je saigne un peu je sais c'est dégueulasse vraiment tout ça pour des bonbons putain si
encore c'était pour des abonnés ou des vues, je comprendrais mais des bonbons quoi enfin, on a tous vécu à l'école primaire des situations on s'est sentis
immensément c*n, voire même humilié mon frère et moi avons cinq ans et demi d'écart ce qui veut dire que quand je suis arrivé au
cp il quittait le cm2 en quittant le cm2 j'ai hérité
littéralement de toute sa collection de jouets à la mode parce qu'il allait rien en faire au collège, il allait juste passer pour un gros
loser auprès des 4e 3e qui sont ceux qui t'intéresse quand tu es en sixième
à l'époque la mode c'était pas les pogs, c'était pas les billes c'était les jojo's mon pote
Les jojo's c'était des petits monstres qu'il fallait collectionner un peu comme les cartes pokémon d'acheter un sachet de jojo's et tu priais pour
qu'il y ait des jojo's rares dedans, mon frère ayant torché ce truc pendant trois ans c'était le king des jojo's
le king de l'école, un soir ils m'offre son sachet rempli
de jojo's, y avait des jojo's brillants mec, les brillances ils étaient méga rare, je suis trop content je me dis putain
demain je vais être le king de l'école c'est sûr à la cantine tout le monde va me filer sa portion de frites il est 11
heures 50 c'est la récréation je force pour ouvrir le sachet et là ça tourne très très mal
en ouvrant le sachet je me foire et tous les jojo's
vol en dehors du sachet et tombe à mes pieds il y avait plus de jojo's à mes pieds que y'avait de bonbons la
fois où j'ai pété le bocal là je me sens pas bien du tout je me dis putain
ça se trouve y en a un qui a roulé à l'autre bout de l'école je retrouverai jamais et comme par hasard ça va être
un brillant ce qui se passe c'est pire que ça mec
Tous les élèves de la cour se retourne vers moi un à un
ils ont tous la même idée au même moment au même endroit courir pour me voler des jojo's ayant compris leur mauvaise intention je
me jette à terre pour ramasser le plus de jojo's possible avant qu'il me les vols sur 80 de jojo's restait 30
sur les 30 il me restait 0 jojo's rare
deuxième moment de ma vie où je me suis senti très très mal
humilié c'était le même sentiment que quand avec ta meuf depuis dix ans et tu te sépares à si si, quand j'étais petit j'étais hyper fan
de laurie de ta meilleure amie de sur un air latino de je vais vite
MMMMMM "Bruit bizarre"
ma mère m'avait acheté une photo d'elle à l'époque mon frère se moquer de moi car il disait que j'étais amoureux de laurie je n'étais
pas amoureux de laurie ok et moi j'avais le seum je voulais trouver mon frère me respecte donc je lui disais non non vasi je
suis pas fan de laurie je répondais ça à l'époque mais il insistait des lucas j'insiste acquiert une photo d'elle sous tournis
un jour il me met à l'épreuve il me lance un challenge
vous savez ce que c'est le challenge qu'on a 10 ans ça va pas lui car tu es vraiment pas amoureux d'elle mais nous vous
renvoyons je suis pas un vieux mec
vraiment oui il respecte mon grand frère ok alors pour le mois en dessinant un doigt d'honneur sur la photo de laurie
à doigt d'honneur mec la violence je prends mon courage à deux mains
Et là mon frère m'a dit une phrase qui ne sera jamais gravé dans ma mémoire il me dit ok bon je te crois quand
même pas
J'ai fondu en larmes je pleurais de toutes mes forces en touchant la photo comme ça avec la paume de ma main cette si belle
photo de lorie et mon frère est allé jouer dans la cour avec ses potes me laissant seul moi et mon ex
quand j'étais à l'école primaire j'ai failli me faire enlever me faire kidnapper mais vraiment un matin je les seuls à l'école primaire comme d'hab
j'avais passé l'âge où ma mère m'emmenait fin elle m'enmmenait des fois mais bon elle m'avait après il ya les soldats à
dire non aux inconnus sur m'approcher etc
Ma mère a fait son travail de mère à la perfection sur ça c'est à dire que j'étais pas
naïf je marche sur le chemin de l'école je me dis "ahh on vas apprendre des maths c'est cool ça me gratte un peu l'oreille on verra
ça en fin de journée" vous avez compris parce que le jeu marche sur le trottoir et une voiture se met à rouler à ma
vitesse juste à côté de moi la porte arrière s'ouvre et un mec me dit la phrase la plus cliché du monde alors gamin tu
vas à l'école c'est énervant l'école tu peux pas venir avec moi plutôt on va s'amuser j'ai plein de jouets chez moi et regarde j'ai même
des bonbons et je sais que vous vous dites que c'est trop cliché et glauque pour être vrai mais c'est vrai je m'en souviens très
bien ça m'a traumatisé donc là comme un enfant de 8 ans je me chivres littéralement dessus quoi et ya une meuf qui arrive en
face de moi avec une poussette et en voyant la poussette je me dis ok elle est maman
bah j'ai fait un genre que c'est ma maman à moi et du coup j'ai couru vers cette femme que je connaissais pas en disant
maman maman il ya un monsieur qui me proposent des bonbons et dans sa voiture il a fallu une seconde à la femme pour comprendre
et elle a regardé le mec dans la voiture et là le mec a fermé la porte et il a tapé un
et la maman m'a dit 'ça va était rien fait tu veux je te ramène chez toi et je lui ai dit non non je
à l'école
les études avant tout je veux offrir un bel avenir à ma famille l'enfant trop intellectuel
j'ai dit non je voulais aller à l'école primaire et oublier ce qui venait de se passer donc j'ai chialé sur le chemin je suis
arrivé à l'école primaire et voilà ce cliché du mec qui propose des bonbons à des enfants pour les enlever ça existe vraiment et si
ta mère ta pas sensibilisé des dizaines voire des centaines de fois vis-à-vis de ça va tu te rends pas compte de la situation et
tu rejoins le mec dans sa voiture quoi tu imagines avec le premier youtuber gaming ce serait un Amixem c'est chiant quand même
je t'aime Amixem
on était fan de pistolets à bille quand on était petit et avec mon frère on était posée dans le salon il y avait plus
de meubles y avait plus rien on se faisait chier on devait attendre et on avait juste un gun a billes pour nous occuper et j'ai lancé un
pari à mon frère je lui ai dit florent est ce quelqu'un tu vois la bille par terre à l'autre bout de la pièce
ouais si tu arrives à la touché et en tirant dessus
eh ben je t'achète ce que tu veux tu as le droit un chargeur pas plus donc 13 billes mon frère il se prend
pour rick de walking dead il fait ok et gamin je m'en occupe
mais fait moins la promesse de m'offrir une gibson sg standard si j'y arrive je le dis oui il tire une bille
2 billes, 3 billes, tous ensemble.
4 billes c'est insupportables il tire la dernière bille et touche l'autre bille qui était à 4 mètres de nous par terre mon frère me regarde
il a le chapeau de rick sur la tête d'un coup je près ce qui s'est passé tu me l'offres quand tu veux mais avant
notre mort
après ça chaque année on a parlé au moins trois fois de ce pari parce que ça nous faisait trop rire c'était tellement improbable et
il ya deux ans grâce à l'argent que je gagne grâce à youtube grâce à vous j'ai pu lui faire la surprise
de lui offrir une gibson sg standard
Et voilà les amis c'est déjà la fin  de cette vidéo sur quand j' était enfant à l'école primaire j'sais pas si je parler comme ça mais
voilà n'hésitez pas à l'aimer si ça vous a plu
moi ça me fait toujours marrer de raconter les les trucs comme ça qu'ils m'ont vraiment marqué y en a pas beaucoup je pense que
là vraiment avec ces trois vidéos
on a un peu fait le tour hésitez pas à me dire vous si vous avez vécu un truc un peu ouf un peu
humiliant ou quoi quand vous étiez jeune mais inventer pas un truc pour faire l'intéressant c'est chiant franchement sur le net il ya trop de
ça et c'est un peu énervant je vous dis merci je vous aide à 13,2 prochaine vidéo portez vous bien et surtout n'oubliez pas dit
toujours non quand un inconnu vous propose un bonbon
Correction des fautes faites par Coserphis!